live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show so we help you win in your
life specifically your money your work
and your relationships all three of
those are absolutely connected and we
want to help you win some common sense
and hope I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by
my colleague Rachel Cruz and we're here
together for you this hour the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
she took a swig from her Rachel Cruz mug
that tells me she is ready to go let's
go we're gonna just have lunch you just
had lunch yes that must be nice I just
came straight from the Ken Coleman show
I won't eat till later today oh we're so
it's okay what a hard life
look at me I'm a real worker here folks
all right let's get to Jose who joins us
in Houston Texas Jose how can we help
how's it going we're having a blast
what's going on
um so I recently graduated college
um I have a full-time job I'm 23 years
old I'm that free I'm staying with my
parents and my question was should I be
aggressive towards saving 50 of my
income Source retirement right now or
should I be
um more aggressive towards saving for
dumping for a house or can I do both
focus in one and also
um my my job
um we have the opportunity to contribute
to a Roth 401k so I'm not um I'm still
confused whether
um if I am going towards the retirement
of uh 15 of my income the route should I
uh should I go towards my Roth or 1K
first or my Roth IRA account and yeah
yeah it's a great question great
questions
um and so I'm assuming you have no debt
yes no no debt and a fully funded
emergency fund
yes yes I forgot to mention um six
months six months okay so you have it
all that's great Jose okay so the next
step I would do yes is to save up for
your down payment which is baby step 3B
and my question for you is too are you
gonna be in the Houston area do you see
yourself there long term or just because
you're so young and I know you're just
maybe a year or two into the workforce
um or do you see yourself maybe moving
because where you are location wise the
length of time you're there probably
will determine for me uh when you're
going to really aggressively save up for
that down payment
yes I do plan on staying in the Houston
area okay for a long time yeah that's
great yeah so if I were you I would look
around and you know whether it's a town
home condos or even you know a single
family home uh and look at some prices
and in the areas you want and then I
would start saving for a down payment
because if you're going to be planted
there for a while uh having a house I
mean it's a it's a great investment and
so I would work towards that first and
that's maybe step 3B is what we call it
and then moving on to maybe step four
which is 15 of your income into
retirement so since both of those the
retirement question of the Roth IRA
versus the Roth 401k since they're both
roths those are both excellent because
they're going to grow tax-free which is
great so I would go up to the match in
the 401K then go and fund your Roth IRA
as much as possible and for some reason
if you Max it out uh and you still don't
hit that 15 of your income you can go
back to your 401k and put some more
money in yeah Jose I got to ask you as
we look forward here
uh what's your relationship status or do
we have something going on there uh or
are we single and ready to mingle
yeah you can say I'm singing already all
right now the reason I asked that first
question is not to be nosy uh so you are
single and so we don't know what's going
to happen in that stage of your life and
so as you begin to look I love Rachel's
advice I I just want to be maybe the
older brother if I well let's be honest
I'm old enough to be your dad this is
embarrassing so I'm going to be radio
dad for a second I just want you to be
really careful because you get out there
you know you've done a great job you're
financially in a wonderful place don't
try to bite off too much you know I mean
you could buy a smaller house it'd be
great for you maybe get some roommates
if if the relationship thing doesn't pan
out right away we don't know what life
is going to throw at us and then maybe
pay that off
and then sell it and move that into the
next house you know I just think Rachel
there's a Temptation out there and I'm
not saying that Jose has it I'm just
warning against it that you get out
there oh yeah you don't have to impress
a bunch of people with that first house
I love that you mentioned a townhouse I
like a conservative move yeah as he gets
out of the home that's the only thing I
want to say it's going to be the radio
dad there don't try to do too much
you're so young you're in such Financial
stability right now at this young of it
of an age and so just be careful Jose
that's the idea
got it
got it yeah thank you very much all
right man thanks for the call I love
that all right let's go to Lily who
joins us in the City of Angels Los
Angeles California Lily how can we help
hi so um my problem is that um I get out
of debt I don't have a problem I like I
have a plan and I can get out of debt I
just tend to be going back into debt and
I've done that like 10 times and I am
just sick and tired of always going back
into this all right yeah is there a
pattern Lily of things that are
happening circumstantially or maybe
proactively where you just find yourself
going right back into it what's what's
caused is there a theme is there a
pattern
um is this comfortable to have that
money sitting there
um you know the credit cards and then I
I use them and then I pay them off and
then back at it again so it's just
credit card nothing else
yeah it's just credit cards okay
interesting a very simple solution Lily
would be to cut them up so they're not a
Temptation anymore
um I and again that's kind of the black
and white answer
um but for you there's a fear there
Rachel feels like she's there's a
scarcity mentality there Lily do you
have any other debt besides the credit
cards
um I had a car note I've been having
Cardinals for like the past four years
but I paid my last car off so I'm good
oh good okay uh do you have any money
saved
no I do not okay so that's gonna be part
of your problem is that there is a a
realistic fear oh I want a quick
question I wonder Lily are you do you
have any margin if you look at your
budget every every month and when you
get to the end do you have some margin
no margin what is it
I'm pretty much broke that's what it is
uh Rachel here's what I think I think
that the budget is one part of it maybe
I also want to I want to know if income
may need may need to go up and I'm
always the bigger shovel guy here on the
Ramsey show what do you make more money
um twenty five thousand dollars okay all
right so here's our problem I how are
you doing on your budget are you
disciplined
um not really but it's really awkward
because I'm I'm a homemaker but I also
work as a caregiver for my mother
um but my husband pays for everything so
my mom and my husband they're like why
do you keep going into debt and I really
don't understand I'm like I don't know
okay it sounds like we've got a lot
going on here yeah okay so Lily how much
does your husband make
he makes about 75 000 a year okay you
guys have separate incomes I mean
accounts Excuse me yes we do okay let's
do this Lily we're getting more
information which is good news because
we're gonna help you so here's the deal
I want you to hold on we're gonna do a
quick break when we come back folks
we're gonna walk Lily through what she
needs to do we got some pieces we gotta
tie together but Lily please hang on
because it's gonna be okay we're gonna
get you out of this mess all right for
the rest of you thank you so much for
tuning in we're gonna help Lily don't go
anywhere she's Rachel Cruz I'm Ken
Coleman this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you're listening to
the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman joined
by my colleague Rachel Cruz the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five we're here to
talk about your money and as it relates
to your money work whether it be income
issues or you're just feeling stuck you
don't feel like you can leave because of
your debt and getting out of the debt
process well we're here to talk about
all of that the relationship component
to that as well it feels like Rachel
we've got all three of those things
involved in Lily Lily joined us in our
last segment from Los Angeles we have
her with us because as we went to break
we were finding out that Lily has gotten
in and out of debt Rachel about 10 times
and she keeps going back to it we found
out it was just the credit cards we
asked why she said well I'm basically
broke I don't have much left at the end
of the month and I like having the
security of if I need something on their
credit cards we then found out that her
husband makes 75 000. she makes 25 000
feels like they don't have joint bank
account I think she said Lily you can
correct me that my mom and husband pay
for everything so Mom is involved too so
mom's involved so we've got a lot going
on so Lily I want to turn you over to
Rachel here and let's figure out what is
happening financially
okay so Lily for you
um you guys obviously are not you and
your husband specifically are not
working together when it comes to money
what is your mom's role in your life is
she living with you guys how involved is
she
um well she actually like helped me out
like she's like oh like do you need a
little bit of money and then she'll like
send me a hundred dollars and I'm like
oh thank you so yeah she helps me here
and there when I need money okay and
also I'm her caregiver so um I work for
her okay I have to clean her house but
I'm paid through the DPSS okay okay so
you and your husbands together
um where are you is money a conversation
you guys have ever is it that he just
finds out you have credit card debt and
he gets frustrated how do conversations
with money go
um so yeah so usually like because he
pays everything
um I don't really
well we don't really share bank accounts
um I don't really see I need to because
when I was going out my mom always told
me that's not a good idea
um to keep my money apart
um so I usually telling me I'm back in
bed and he helps me face it off but he's
getting kind of tired and I'm getting
kind of tired as well yeah and I'm
taking money from the house so I don't
want to be in debt anymore yeah for sure
well I hear I hear that so I think one
step this is not going to solve all the
problems but a really big step that I
want you to take Lily is for you and
your husband to sit down and I want you
guys to start framing up this new way of
looking at money in your marriage
because I want you guys to start working
together as a team and seeing yourselves
as one right now it is very separate and
you're doing it out of this fear
mentality because your mom always told
you all of this all of this all this
listen when you are married you are one
in every aspect of your life including
your money and it's going to be really
hard Lily to win long-term financially
when you're in a marriage with someone
and you guys are not talking about money
you're not working on money together and
you don't see yourselves as one and so I
know there can be a lot of fear there
but with your husband you guys need to
sit down and say hey we have to start
working to be on the same page because
if you guys start working together you
combine your income Lily you guys will
have a hundred thousand dollars to work
with throughout the year you guys can
sit down do a budget together and say
hey here is where here's where we're
agreeing on where our money's going but
here's what I'm gonna say Lily if I'm
your husband it's gonna be really hard
to trust you if you're in a habit of
going and racking up credit card debt so
you need to get to the bottom and the
root cause of of what is causing it and
I think part of it part of it might be
mathematics because you're just working
off this 25 000 and if it's running out
you're scared and you go to your mom and
you have all these these safety nets so
what you want to be able to do is to say
okay when that fear Rises up I know that
we're working a plan to get us an
emergency fund I know that we're working
a plan to be in control of our money we
me and my husband because you guys
working together but Lily I really would
that one of the best things I've heard
Dr John zaloney say this that if there's
a Temptation in your life
yes you want to get to the root cause of
it but you also want to make it not easy
to continue to repeat yeah the mistake
right so if you're an alcoholic going
and sitting in a bar all the time like
that's not a great plan and so for you
those credit cards just hanging around
it's an easier Temptation because
they're accessible they're right there
so make it I want to make it hard for
you I want to make it hard for you Lily
to go and swipe cards because when
they're not there it's going to be tough
let's do it Lily are you at home right
now
yes I am can you go get your scissors
and pull your credit cards out let's cut
them up right now do it do it I'm
serious are you willing to do it if not
I'll let you go we're not going to
pressure you you will you you ready to
cut them up right now
a lot of noise in my house so I'm
actually in my garage because I haven't
I know an excuse when I hear one because
we're all good at giving them so I tell
you what Lily we're not going to shame
you into this but I'll tell you what we
will do we want to give you a good push
forward we're going to give you
Financial Peace University so hang on
the line and we're going to give you
Financial Peace University I want you to
commit to going through this with your
husband I think Rachel's advice is great
I think your husband deserves you going
hey I want to do whatever it takes so
that you're not tired of bailing me out
and that we're on the same page and so
let's let's see if he'll commit to doing
Financial Peace University with you and
if you follow these steps which you've
bought into the concept of paying off
debt before Lily I mean you've done it
several times and uh we've got to get to
what's really going on here and I think
Rachel's advice is going to take away
this fear
this mindset that I don't have enough
you you feel like you don't have enough
because you don't know what enough is
you've got to get on the same page so
hang on the line we'll give you
Financial Peace University and I really
believe it will help let's go to the Big
Apple next New York City New York and
James is joining us James how can we
help
Hi how are you guys doing today we're
having a blast James what's up
awesome
um so unfortunately I just got laid off
from my job uh selling technology uh I'm
sorry a month ago yeah yeah the whole
business unit was let go yeah we're
seeing that a lot with big Tech what are
you doing now for money
uh so I'm looking very actively for uh a
job however I'm finding that while
um you know I've received even one offer
and I've gotten through some application
processes and I'm glad you're on camera
because I know you've got a great
Insight here
um I haven't found anything that pays
close to what I was making in my last
scroll okay so in my last role how much
were you making
with your commission was uh about 150k a
year but I was looking forward to 250
275 the last three years good for you
um do you have any savings
uh yeah
yeah I have an emergency fund fully
funded for six months
45k and then I got about 20K in
Severance
um well I don't want you touching the
emergency fund you don't have debt
I don't have any data I except for my
mortgage which is a significant amount
of debt all right so we need some income
fast
yeah well so let me just tell you I
understand you're looking for for a role
that pays you 250. I get it because you
settle you set a watermark so we it's
just the natural human thing I want to
get back to that Mark but right now you
need money so while you're looking you
need to be working and if you can get
something that pays 125 uh I mean my
point is is we don't just we can't just
go well I'm looking for 250 and haven't
found it yet it's like we keep looking
for the 250. you've got the experience
you've got some skill set but right now
we've got to bring in some income and
we're going to drastically change our
lifestyle do you understand what I'm
saying
that makes a lot of sense I I my concern
though is just
um you know if I take a job at 125
I can just bear I can pay the mortgage
and I can hit my essentials but putting
like 15 towards retirement and making
the aggressive but brother I'm not
saying I'm not saying take a job for 125
for the next part of your career I'm
saying we've got Financial issues given
your mortgage and your reality if we
don't get urgent and get some income so
I'm saying let's go get income to scrape
by to stay stable nose above water so we
don't go into the emergency fund that
emergency fund is not for floating me
while I find another job James make sure
that your mortgage is not 50 of your
take-home pay because that also could be
a problem so we gotta look at that you
may need to sell that property right now
for a reboot for a restart so hang on
the line can we set James up to to call
into my show next week and let's talk
about his future and some opportunities
there appreciate the call don't move
more of your calls coming up this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today safe
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
joined by my colleague Rachel Cruz a
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you're new to
the program first we want to say welcome
and second we are having a conversation
about money and in the context of
talking about your money we talk about
work and relationships and I'm the work
guy I think about making more money
getting in a better situation to where
you can pay off debt faster save money
faster I'll take those calls today and
of course Rachel Cruz one of our money
experts here at Ramsey Solutions here to
answer your money questions so let's get
to it Omaha Nebraska Beth is on the line
Beth how can we help
about some land we have inherited some
land it's 19 acres has a small home on
it
um part of it is farmable and there's a
guy that does some farming out of that
none of that is very lucrative maybe
um
maybe um 700 a month is what we're
taking in off of that property
so we have it's it's kind of a hot
property in Council Bluffs Iowa things
are kind of moving there there's a lot
of businesses
so we've been approached by somebody
that said they would give us eight
hundred thousand dollars for it it's
probably Market values probably between
250 and 300 000 if we were going to sell
it what they want to do though is pay us
ten thousand the first year 10 000 the
second year
and then 800 if it sells in year three
or if they're ready in year three four
and five they're planning to be done and
have all their permits and ready to do
what they want to do within the five
years they're hoping to be done in three
Beth I gotta tell you I'm wondering Beth
that sounds like pure pers prospecting
this is a company that sees the value
they're over they're over that offer is
crazy to offer that much over market
value and then give you this little
payment plan what they're trying to do
is they're trying to put a hold on this
thing and it sounds sketchy to me
extremely prospective meaning I hope
everything works I hope everything works
and the fact is it sounds to me like you
could get 300 for it in this market
right now and I would take the sure
thing I'd say no that's me Rachel do you
see any problems with that I totally
agree yeah Beth if this was a nine month
thing hey can we hold it for nine months
and then this this and this but you're
talking a year two years three is five
years yeah and the problem is the
company right now can't do what they
want to do so could they in three years
yeah maybe but also could they not yeah
maybe and you just held onto a piece of
property that now are you guys forced to
sell is there a reason you absolutely
have to sell right now
no not at all okay
um do you own it uh free and clear any
debt on the property
no we have no debt I mean even personal
debt we have nothing I mean we wouldn't
sell it to pay anything we don't need we
don't need it right now that's the
question yeah so I would I would almost
tell them like yep I would just tell
them hey I don't want this property I
don't want my word to be tied down to
this property for years and years and
years so we're not going to sell we're
not planning unless you are planning I'm
we're not planning on doing anything so
come back to us in three five three four
years when you actually have the money
to this business and we can evaluate it
and look and then make the decision then
but we're not gonna I'm not you don't
get your name on this property for ten
thousand dollars per year
um you because you don't need to Beth
like you're fine and if you guys want to
sell it
um down the line then you can and you're
gonna make great money do you do you
guys need any of this cash at all in
your situation how old are you guys
63 and 57 no we don't um
yeah the other thing is if even if you
get it in this market what do you do
with it because you don't really want to
invest I don't run too right of this
yeah and you can hold on to it and and
it can continue to grow in value in
maybe 20 years if you want to sell you
can do Beth I I think this is a really
simple response no thanks
okay the other thing we thought of was
going back to him and saying you can pay
us this one year
10 grand and then this time next year we
either settle on the 800 or we're out no
it's too complicated yeah you just got
done telling us that you guys wouldn't
even here's the deal you wouldn't have
called us today had they not made this
offer you guys weren't even thinking
about selling it true or false
true okay then this is sketchy and weird
and they're not even going to be doing
anything for two years so just tell them
keep growing your business and in two
years come back and if you want the same
offer maybe we'll talk about it and
right we can sell it to you then but
yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't attach myself
to them for two years and here's the
deal Beth it is possible I don't think
it's gonna happen I think it's a small
chance but one of my favorite games to
play with my buddies in the old
neighborhood Rachel we're talking small
dollars here but I enjoy poker and if
you want to in this situation you just
say no you call their Bluff
and you say no thanks and then we'll
find out if they're the real deal and if
they are the real deal I don't think
they'd be offering 800 000. that's what
I think is just this is all very
manipulative feeling to me it's just
weird no good business person goes well
the market says it's worth three I'm
gonna come in and offer a half million
more like Rachel's husband wins is a
friend of mine and a real estate expert
he hit me over the head with a bat if I
propose some idea like that so so hey no
thanks Beth and let's just see if
they're for real and if they come to you
with real money uh that makes real sense
then you and the hubs and the family can
talk about it it's great no thanks man
and here's what happens and I get it
Beth I get even the the curiosity is
peaked because you're thinking this
could be a really good deal oh yeah this
could be a good deal but in here's the
thing you know even if she went through
with it let's just pretend she thinks
that we're crazy and she says that and
then they this company gives them ten
thousand dollars to this year next year
and then they have the 800 you know yeah
then you know it can right like people
can keep their word there are times that
it happens but here's the thing is like
you're putting yourself in risk with a
company yeah and there's no need for you
to be tied down to something because
also Beth I would say you never know
what's gonna happen in your life and you
may look up and be like man we just want
to we're gonna move out of Omaha we want
it out of here and it frees you up
there's there's no one owning any part
of it great of your of your life for
this property I think my response is I
wanna I wanna edit my response I'll tell
you what it's the best on the Fly how
are you fellas
um here's my uh I can give you my my
Bankers information and you guys can
wire 800 dollars to our account today
and will show up and we'll have a
marching band and we'll walk you onto
the property
outside of that we're okay we're fine
we're good it just sounds a little crazy
yeah all right let's go to uh Andy now
in Reno do you say Nevada or Nevada
Rachel I say Nevada I think the people
that live out there they say Nevada
Nevada what is it I've been saying
Nevada let's go to Andy Andy is it
Nevada or Nevada
I say Nevada everybody out there does so
that's what I'm sticking with Andy how
can we help
you know I was wanting somebody to help
push me over the edge to pay my mortgage
off well you have found the right two
people to push you over the edge today I
will tell you right now why give me one
good reason that keeps popping up in
your head as to why you wouldn't pay it
off
you know I'm not sure
um maybe just the complications of
having to pay my own insurance and taxes
from now on you got the money to pay
your mortgage off today
I do wow
Rachel yeah I mean Andy is not that much
more complicated I mean yes you will
have to pay for yeah your insurance it's
not all wrapped up together and your
property tax you know our house is paid
off you pay it once a year and it
sucker punches you in the gun you're
like but that's all you've got but
that's it I mean yeah so you just I mean
there there's really besides the
emotional like oh man even though you
were paying the same amount of property
tax so over 12 months obviously uh but
yeah there's just like they're they're
it's not even it's not even
um debatable for me of the complications
of insurance and paying your taxes on
your own versus keeping your mortgage
there yeah is that all wrapped into your
current mortgage payment now
it is so you do realize that they can
also wrap those two together or automate
them for you I mean you're acting like
this is going to be a real pain in the
neck and I'm not sure that I understand
how painful it's going to be if you
don't have a mortgage payment
okay well I don't think it's too much of
a pain in the neck but that would be the
only reason that I would have so that's
why I used it well I'm here to push you
my friend my goodness so if you pay all
this off Andy how much do you have in
retirement how much do you have liquid
so liquid cash right now I have just
under 140. okay
[Music]
um my retirement I have 6 30 and a 401k
and about 125 in a Roth IRA and what's a
house worth
[Music]
um well these days probably around 5 30.
dude Andy how much is how much is left
on it what do you have to write the
check for
[Music]
1573k 73k oh Andy what are you waiting
on do it do it just do it
in the week in the week with a paid off
house pay it off Andy now we gotta pay
some bills we'll be right back it says
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
thrill that you are with us I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz my
co-host is our triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the phone
number to jump in that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five well
debt is at an all-time high as it
relates to credit cards so those debt
payments and now inflation which is just
stubbornly staying around it's stealing
more and more of your paycheck and we
know that a lot of you feel like you're
just trying to keep your nose above
water and you're scared to death but you
shouldn't have to live that way
but if you want things to change you
have to say I've had it no more
and you need to try something new and we
have something new to you maybe but it
is proven for decades Financial Peace
University is our nine lesson course
that will teach you how to beat debt and
build wealth
nearly 10 million people have taken
Financial Peace University and they'll
tell you they don't worry about money
like they used to I've said this before
when we talk to debt free screamers on
this show during this time of inflation
I've never heard one of them gripe about
inflation now nobody likes it but it's
not squeezing them too hard and you can
get there as well if you're done
stressing about money take control by
starting Financial Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
slash
FPU and also to new listeners and
viewers welcome
people are finding this through all of
the different platforms today and you
hear jargon you hear language you may be
not sure what's going on don't worry
we've created a simple solution for you
to get caught up on the language and the
philosophy and the methodology of the
show it's ramseysolutions.com and you'll
see a get started button click on that
and we're going to walk you through our
plan help you figure out where you are
in this journey this clear path that
we've created it'll help you out so
again
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started all right let's go to Cincinnati
Ohio Tony is there Tony how can we help
hello thank you for taking my call can
you hear me very well what's up
hi so um long story short uh I lost my
job today and
um I'm so sorry yeah what happened well
thank you
um basically I was having um sort of uh
mental health issues and my employer uh
uh let me know that that it wasn't gonna
work for me to leave uh today so I chose
I chose to leave and it just didn't
didn't work out okay how comfortable are
you sharing your mental health uh
situation or challenges
um
well uh so uh mainly anxiety but a
little bit of some psychotic symptoms uh
thrown in there and uh
and that's uh something I'm working on
okay
um you know you've seen a professional
right now
yeah yes I am okay good yes and so I'm
assuming that you've had some of these
struggles for a while and have had to
leave work
and at this point the manager was like
you can't go you needed to go today you
felt like you needed to to walk away and
they said no and you had to choose is
that what I'm understanding
that that is uh that is correct but um
basically I didn't communicate this well
with my manager so I'm taking
responsibility for that part of it as
well okay and I'm listen I applaud that
Tony I mean you know moving forward
because that's where you're at I mean
today you've decided to move on and in
moving forward I want to applaud you and
encourage you number one your bravery
and transparency to share this kind of
stuff on a live show and number two to
say you know what I didn't do a good job
communicating this and I've got to learn
from that so I want to applaud you so
how can we help you today specifically
um basically my uh Financial Peace
University class starts in about two
weeks and uh
I don't have any money and I don't know
what the next right thing to do is okay
so let's just walk through your money
situation really quick what were you
making were you salary or hourly and
what were you making hourly okay so what
were you making per hour
and what kind of work were you doing
it was a food service Food Service Okay
so
here's the good news
um America's restaurants and food
service uh certainly uh anything related
to the service industry whether that be
touristic heavy or just in a community
they are absolutely bleeding looking for
people and you've got experience and I
don't think they're going to be too
concerned uh about your backstory as
long as you own it and you just kind of
go hey here's my situation I need a job
I was over here uh I was like go on I
need to work and I think if you are a
decent human being and you sound that
way you've shown some real maturity and
some real fortitude uh through this
process and you just you got to start
working I mean like that's our first
step
um we have got to get a new opportunity
and this time around when you have some
episodes or some things you're
struggling with
you need your professional counselor to
help you with some tools
to manage that in that environment and
if they're saying the best thing for you
to do is to step away for a moment
you're going to have to ask that
professional help me do that in a
professional context because I'm here
and I'm working is it something that I
can do uh you know in a matter of
minutes
or is this way heavier than this and so
if that's the case if it's way heavier
and I'm way above my skis here when
somebody starts talking about psychotic
stuff you're going to have to go what
work can I do
to where essentially I am working for
myself or I'm in a contract situation to
where I'm bringing in money but I've got
a lot more freedom to step away when I
need to do you understand what I'm
saying we're going to have to maybe get
a little bit more intentional to find a
work environment that is best for you in
this season does that make sense
that does make sense yes does anything
come to mind Tony besides just being in
the rest being in a restaurant and you
know whether you're cook or waiting
tables is there another type of job that
might be less stressful or on demand
that having to be on so on demand is
there another thing that you're thinking
of that you could do and could be
qualified for
well I I do have a a big dream that I'm
working towards but it doesn't pay the
bills right now yeah no this is not a
big dream question so for instance is it
let me throw yourself some potential
scenarios uh were you in Waiting tables
is that what you were doing in food
service
no it's more
um on the prep side cooking and okay
great so you're in the kitchen all right
so I'm wondering
um
is there a difference in the stress
level or the environment if maybe you
were stocking shelves on an evening
shift in a grocery store versus being in
a kitchen that's maybe High pace how
does that feel is there a difference in
those two as far as maybe the
environment that could be more helpful
that that's a that's a I haven't thought
of that before but
yeah that's why I'm saying I'd love for
you to sit with your counselor if you've
got an emergency line or whatever and
how you talk to your counselor I I'm
ask my professional yeah what are the
things that maybe uh trigger certain
things what's the best environment from
a mental health professional here and
then that's where we start to go okay
maybe this environment's not the best
for me this is better while I am I have
to stay in it while I'm getting healthy
and I want to acknowledge you're in a
very complex situation but I think you
can do this and I think if if as you
went like that I think those are the
questions you've got to be able to ask
where can I make 15 50 an hour
that is a better environment for me
that's where we've got to start but I
really want you to run that by your
mental health counselor as well because
they know things that a we don't know B
they're professionally trained to be
able to give you good Insight on that
yeah and start thinking outside the box
Tony but if you find yourself Paralyzed
by the decision and freaking out there
is a reality to life like you gotta have
money coming in you got to do it so
maybe for you know you find another
restaurant for 60 90 days or you're
doing ubereats delivering pizza like
getting your car and deliver some food
that's right yep yeah doing something
different but you need to find something
that you can that has a really easy
entry point because here in the next
couple days I mean if you really have no
money you gotta eat so you you have to
go and decide okay I have to bring in
some level of income and then from there
Tony I'm so glad that you're doing
Financial Peace University
um because that's going to help you so
much understand how to budget your money
that's going to give you a level of
control it's gonna feel really great if
you have debt it's going to give you a
plan to help pay that off and then get
some Savings in an emergency funds and
all of this is a marathon it just it's
going to like if a year or two three
four years but continue to be consistent
Tony and yeah we're cheering you on we
really are thanks a lot of Tony we're
going to give you John deloney's book
redefining anxiety hopefully that helps
you on your journey as well great hour
Rachel Cruz thank you to James Childs
and the entire team keep us on the air
thank you America this is your show this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money and
then we look at the work angle in the
relationship angle to the central money
issue I'm so excited that you're with us
I'm Ken Coleman I drove by my colleague
Rachel Cruz we're here for you this hour
taking your questions specialize in
those work related issues that affect
your money and then Rachel is our money
expert and let's be honest
uh fashion uh home economic tips menu
items cooking on a budget anything mom
uh related she's really good at that too
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number and speaking of
I don't mean to stir things up yes I do
um I follow you on the gram the old
Graham the old install and stuff and uh
recently you uh put something out there
of our beloved
Chick-fil-A we all love Chick-Fil-A
around here oh yeah but uh you told a
story about you and Winston and the
kiddos and you went to uh Chick-fil-A
and I believe the bill for all five of
you might have been over forty dollars
if memory serves yes correct and you
just were like wow a little bit of
sticker shock that's inflation in real
world sure terms yeah and I understand
that you got lit up yes well exactly
because you made some controversy we
were here me and Jade right we're
hosting the show it was a week or two
ago oh and we were talking about saving
money and
um how much things cost and I said yeah
we went out to Chick-fil-A we usually go
to Chick-fil-A on Tuesday nights because
everyone is that a thing yeah because
Amelia has gymnastics and it's kind of
our like routine it's one of those
things you do yep and usually I load my
Chick-fil-A app with money so I just go
and scan it you know when I drive up to
make it easy right well this one I I
didn't have money on the app so I had to
actually like reload it and then I just
realized the total uh and it's probably
been like this for a little bit but
again it just hit me that day for some
reason it was 40 one dollars and I was
like man
41 for three kids meals I got an adult
meal Winston just got I think just a
chicken sandwich so again this isn't
hating on Chick-fil-A I was just saying
that's 41 and I said here on the show I
could make four to five meals for forty
one dollars that could last us four oh
boy did you get a little more pissed at
me and I said this so why do you think
that is before we get into the details
of it because you actually prove it in
an Instagram too I'm gonna pull this up
but we're gonna get to that yes all
right because she's gonna actually prove
the haters wrong but I I before we get
to that yeah why do you think it was
such a visceral reaction to saying that
well and I was kind of being facetious
anyways I just kind of threw out a
number I was I wasn't like in my head
had this calculate calculated so if
someone just said to me you can make
four meals for forty dollars I may even
be like really can I I don't know
because I just know my grocery bill
every week it's like anger but they and
so I mean and it went into everything
from clean eating to Cal I live in
California to I mean every everything
you could imagine and and I'm like yes
food is expensive and food is a hot
button right now in general like even
the grocery stores like it's just life
is expensive but I know I mean I meal
plan so I'm like I know what I can make
I can make some cheap meals so this is
the post that I saw so I kept just
watching these comments come in and I
just finally got tired I usually don't
get too stirred up by the gram and it
started pissing me off because I was
like this isn't true though like like
everyone's like you're This Woman's
crazy I'm like no I'm not you actually
can't do this so I went um Kroger
clicklist that night laying in bed lay
this out this is where my notes app My
Notes app up and I'll say I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna get on kroger.com right
now and I'm gonna I'm gonna research off
meal plan for 40 bucks yep okay once you
come up and I got you four meals Ken are
you ready for this I'm very excited here
we go okay so you buy a pack of meat a
pack of meat ground beef yes now these
meals are not elaborate but then they're
not vegan either no and they're probably
not clean whatever whatever it's like
clean eating that's what we eat in
America so and this is for our family of
three little kids I have 16 teenagers
I'm like okay I'm sorry okay I don't
know what to do with that so I take a
pack of ground beef and you cut it in
half okay put half of the meat ground it
up put it in a jar of spaghetti sauce
boom uh jars so that uh one jar six
dollars for a pack of meats okay get a
jar of sauce for two dollars that's the
cheap sauce cheap sauce just go Kroger
Brand This is just yeah we're just
putting and then you buy noodles
you can buy 100 pounds of noodles
there's a box of Kroger noodles for a
dollar penne noodles
you got you a big old bowl of pasta
right there and the kids are fine okay
no no I'm sorry that's uh that's not
once meal one meal one nine bucks okay
so we're gonna take the same the other
other half the other half of me okay
yeah you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna ground that up salt pepper all the
things and you're gonna get tortilla
shells three dollars three dollars
Mexican cheese for two dollars a
shredded cheese
um uh what are those black beans for a
dollar can of black beans is a dollar
and rice
is I found a dollar a thing of rice for
a dollar so I got seven on that one okay
quesadillas yeah cheese quesadillas
throw some meat in if if you want some
meat in it yeah no and then you got rice
and beans in this but like you have
little kids that's okay
you're the teenager no that's the cheese
cheese
quesadilla people I know but I'm just
saying like that you've cut one pound of
meat up into two and I'm just saying I
see where the criticism starts to come
in okay well no but but the kids are
gonna you're still right the cheese
quesadillas we're gonna eat the cheese
and if you want to sprinkle some meat
for a little bit of protein yeah it
needs the meat okay you take the meat
you take the meat I'm just trying to
keep it right I know but I don't eat
cheese quesadillas
oh man that in our house that's a meal
okay all right so that's Pizza in this
segment I have a feeling already like no
they're gonna love it you're right but
then you're gonna get some chicken for
the next meal seven dollars chicken for
seven okay yep and then you're gonna be
sharing Ramsay open up your spice
cabinet 100 put some spices in there
if you have any lemon juice garlic salt
yeah uh throw some um uh olive oil all
of it marinate the chicken okay get some
naan for three dollars hummus for three
dollars a tomato for 50 cents green
onion for a dollar
and then another box of rice for for a
dollar okay so you're gonna do a Greek
Bowl yeah so you're gonna do the rice at
the bottom Chicken on top impressive
hummus and then you're gonna take your
tomatoes and your green onions slice
them all up in a bowl put the same olive
oil on with salt and pepper a little bit
uh if you have any red wine vinegar in
there too yeah it's great it's a good
Greek and then pizza and then pizza
dough two things a pizza dough for seven
dollars the rest of the cheese from the
Mexican and then another jar of sauce
for a dollar you got two pieces so we've
got three four meals so we have it on
the screen for our viewing audience I
was trying to keep up with it with the
old pencil there it is all of that right
there 43.50 now for those of you vegans
out there I'm sorry you know you just
are gonna have to spend more money
because of yours and then here's the
deal too get romaine lettuce you can get
three three romaine hearts for like I
don't know I'm scared to say prices
everyone's getting mad at me three
dollars cut it up in a salad get some
you can get some fruits and vegetables
uh frozen vegetables it's like a dollar
for a bag of frozen broccoli so here
so as the dad who doesn't pay attention
to the grocery list let me tell you what
I'm taking away from this you're making
an actual real point to say
unless you've got some really intense
dietary needs or some choices you're
making yes
you can eat for less and this is real
budget stuff because people spend
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
dollars on groceries and that's it and
don't go out to eat if you're if you're
gonna be done yes now this is for a
season but hey don't get me started on
leftover spaghetti if you buy enough of
the noodles you could make two meals
okay then throw in an extra buck and get
another get another box of noodles you
know for another dollar so it can be
done it can be done great stuff Rachel
Cruz she's got you covered you bet all
right folks now the controversy and
dissension is done more help on the way
relax
take a shot of the Sig we'll be back
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
all right welcome back America you've
joined the Ramsey Show here I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz and uh
well it's Friday Rachel do you have any
Friday Traditions uh in the cruise
household it's usually pizza and movie
night nice yeah
well uh there's not a better way to
start off the weekend than by setting
yourself up for success with your money
the fun way how about some tickets to
our final Building Wealth live events of
the Season you can catch uh me George
Campbell Rachel Cruz Dave Ramsey and uh
wait a second who's it's just you and
George
and Dave in Salt Lake City sorry I got
ahead of myself the Salt Lake date is
you and Dave and uh George and Jade
orshaw that's April the 24th and then I
got ahead of myself Anaheim California
uh I'll be out there with Dave Dr John
deloney and Jade warshoff so we've kind
of split the crew up this has been a fun
tour yeah so you're heading to Salt Lake
I don't I don't mind telling you I'm
glad to be in Anaheim I like I know
you're in Salt Lake Salt Lake's a
beautiful city it's great it is it's
wonderful La is great y'all did Austin
we did Austin together Indianapolis yeah
yeah so gonna be a lot of fun and this
is an event that is going to help you
learn how to build lasting wealth the
kind that'll change your family tree all
the Building Wealth live events this
spring have sold out so we're expecting
that to continue uh the general
admission tickets for these two dates
are still available for only 49 and you
can get a four pack of tickets for only
175 dollars get your tickets today at
ramseysolutions dot com slash events
ramseysolutions.com
events all right let's go to Richmond
Virginia uh Kim is on the line Kim how
can we help
yes hi uh Ken and Rachel thanks for
taking my call
um so here's the thing I'm hesitant
about paying my student loan so that's
my question I'm hesitant about starting
paying my student loan debt uh that's
the only dad I have right now
um I recently
was um got a promotion
and I'm just nervous about just starting
how much do you have at all how much do
you have left how much do I have oh yeah
how much left
865 and probably 91 okay and I have like
20 K saved up okay and how much are you
making now in this new job
in this new job
oh
I'm
okay but after like taxes I'll probably
bring home like 20 percent of that so
like 30. sure yeah
okay so yeah Kim if I were you
um you know that I understand the
hesitation of draining savings because
you're like oh my gosh you know it feels
like there's a huge safety net there
that feels good that feels right and
then taking some of that and throwing it
at the debt is going to be really hard
but what we've real well we've realized
over honestly decades here at Ramsey
Solutions is the fastest way for you to
build wealth from point A to point B is
to get debt out of your life and to be
so intense and so focused on paying this
off because as you are paying on your
student loans uh you're going to
continue to see that income your income
leave and those payments interest all of
it and so when you have no payments and
nothing getting taken out of your
paycheck when it hits your account you
are able to save back that emergency
fund that twenty thousand dollars so
quickly you're able to start investing
you're able to start letting your money
work for you but as you keep the student
loan around
continually it's just chipping away at
your income and so I understand that
it's scary Kim but if I were you I would
I would throw nineteen thousand dollars
at it and I would take a huge chunk out
of it you're gonna you know have 66 left
and I would start looking for even
another way to possibly get a second job
and start making even more than that 50
000 and again this is for a season but I
would do what I can to throw as much
money as possible at the student loan
and get it get it out as fast as
possible
so here's my second hesitation I have an
older car and like I'm thinking like
well what is this it's like a lot of
what is you know yep absolutely yeah how
what what's the mileage on your car is
it breaking down now what what's
happening or is it just the idea that
it's old
it's the idea that's it it's just the
idea yep which which is understandable
and here's the deal too if the car does
completely go out in two years and you
still have student loan debt then you
pause the debt snowball you pause paying
off your debt you save up some cash and
you go and buy something else and you
upgrade and sell the car that you have
so you you can do that through this
process
um and so things might happen but here's
the deal they might or that car could
last you another five years Beyond you
being debt free and have an emergency
fund
but Kim that's true here's the if I
could give you maybe a mental hack on
this you've got to look at this a little
bit differently and say okay
um if I had some medical emergencies or
if I had some things that are happening
medically I've got to take care of me
right and and so taking care of you is
getting this debt out of your life but
there are times where things happen and
we can't do it all at once but to go
ahead and start making the progress and
as Rachel said I can downshift at any
time so when bad things happen and they
do you're gonna have to deal with them
you have to deal with them but we don't
not take care of another problem because
we're worried about another problem that
could happen we address the problem in
front of us and then what a bigger more
important problem happens we go oh I
gotta take care of it right and so if
you had health issues we would take care
of you first if we have a car issue we
take care of the car first but we still
want to knock this out and I think what
you're going to find and what we found
over decades is when somebody gets super
intentional and serious about paying off
the debt and you start this thing with
big momentum by doing what Rachel told
you a nineteen thousand dollar payment
on this wow that's some serious progress
and now you go what must I do to knock
this out in the next two years what
would it take to knock it out in three
years and just begin to visualize what
progress could look are you married Kim
so you're in a really great position
honestly
um that that you're meeting your time
and everything is yours yes so yeah this
is the time to get a second job even a
third job I mean go as a scorched Earth
as possible Kim and this because what
also on the other end when you have no
Sallie Mae when you have no payments no
student loans there's nothing attached
to your name financially what that gives
you is a level of Peace that's why we
call it Financial Peace then you you
have you can't even experience you don't
even you don't even know the feeling of
going to bed at night and knowing you
don't owe anyone anything freeze up
something within your mental health it
frees something up in your spirit and
your emotions where you're just free but
here's the problem is a lot of people
especially with student loans because
they're usually a large amount and
they're so normalized that people like
ah just keep it around so long it feels
like a pet and it's just another thing
here at the house and we just kind of
keep it and keep on moving and so in
order to get it out it's almost like you
have to fight that much harder to be
that much more angry at it find some
anger in there and be like I am so
frustrated and I'm gonna spend two years
of my life and throwing everything I
have at the set and then once it's paid
off then Kim you're like oh imagine what
I have nothing to do I love that Rachel
Kim I hope you heard what Rachel just
said you got to get mad at that debt
because you got to say this debt is
holding me back from let's fill in a
couple blanks what is it holding you
back from
and then on the other side of this as
Rachel's saying you're not going to have
that payment and you're going to be able
to do something with that money that you
were spending to pay off the debt but
even more important Rachel I find that
Kim you're gonna walk out of this and go
I paid off sixty six thousand dollars or
whatever the number is I can now save
this up over the next two to three years
and buy my own house I mean once you've
come on the other side of that
unbelievably difficult accomplishment
yep it's not just that you removed the
hurdle it's that you know you can do
something else like that except this
time it's not a hurdle this time it's
something that I desire
do you understand what I'm saying Kim
you got this you can do this it feels
impossible but I'm telling you almost
that's a great Point Ken it's it's the
financial it's the emotional and then
it's also just knowing that I can do
something hard yeah and something that
feels impossible and that momentum boost
and confidence boost is something that I
mean everyone can benefit from so Kim uh
we are cheering you on you can do this
and we're gonna get you into Financial
Peace University hang on the line I want
you to be around some people who are on
a similar Journey going after it there's
strength in numbers there's strengthen
Community you need to get involved in an
FPU class I promise you it'll fire you
up hang on the line we're gonna take
care of you Kim you got this all right
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman and I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz we're here for you this hour
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right so it's time for our question
of the day uh the Ramsey Show question
of the day is sponsored by neighborly
your hub for home services from repairs
and maintenance to Remodeling and
upgrades neighborly's trusted Home
Services provide providers rather have
trained local experts who can handle
just about any job so go to
neighborly.com to find and schedule
service today
all right so today's question comes from
Christina in Oklahoma how does an HSA
account come into play with the
emergency fund we're currently in baby
step three and before beginning the baby
steps we had planned to have at least
the cost of our health insurance
deductible 7 500 for our family
remaining in our HSA at all times my
question is should we have this 7 500
for the HSA in addition to the 20 000
emergency fund or should we consider the
7 500 part of the emergency funds we
have paused contributions and we'll pick
it back up again once our debt is paid
off do we have the option to invest the
HSA much like an IRA what do you all
recommend uh and how we should save and
what do you think and how do you think
we should invest our HSA okay lots of
HSA questions here
um okay so Christina if you guys are in
baby step three so I would just consider
all health and those and all of that for
me I would just put that in your
emergency fund of your twenty thousand
dollars and then I would start to look
at your HSA as an investment vehicle
just like you're saying you could
actually start investing this when it
gets to a certain amount and it starts
to grow and become another another
vehicle within retirement so if you can
cash flow your deductible uh I would use
the HSA more as an investment vehicle
than for health and it's kind of a
different way of looking at it but if
you talk to one of our smartvestor Pros
when it comes to all of your investing
because once you're finished up with
baby step three you'll move on the baby
step four I would recommend looking into
it because I think it's a great option
and again this is great if you can cash
flow that stuff out of your emergency
fund or even just out of your paycheck
if you just have money there that you're
able to say hey we can actually just put
this within the budget when things come
up health issues come up uh it's a it's
a great option so that's what we
personally do in the cruise household
we've used our HSA
um and fully funded it every year but
you looked at it more on the retirement
end of the spectrum when it comes to
investing than using it for health so
it's a great question Christina yes
thank you so much all right let's go to
Chicago Illinois now where Juan is
waiting One how can we help
uh yes
um almost all of my uh baby step two I'm
not going to be after that I have about
12 000 left but I'm a part-time teacher
and a lot of my students have told me I
should teach money on basic computer
classes online because there's a lot of
people out there that need to learn how
to use computers I love teaching I'm a
passionate about it but I'm not not sure
how to start my own business with that
okay well uh your students are right one
um in fact now is uh really the best
time in our history of our world to
truly just go boom I'm gonna start uh
tutoring or teaching and offering my
services online so the way I would start
is I would just do some basic research I
would just do some research to see what
kind of com what kind of competition you
might have out there this is not just
related to the Chicago area just let's
look across the country and what are
people offering uh for computer tutoring
or computer teaching classes see what's
out there what organizations may be
looking to hire people like you because
you wouldn't believe how many companies
are out there looking for teachers who
can come in and be a part of their
roster if you will so I would look at
both sides of the aisle just to get an
idea of what I can make and that's going
to take a lot of the intimidation Factor
away but as far as starting it goes it's
as simple as once you figure out what
you would teach and how so what you
would be offering after you've done that
research this is just you telling your
students to spread the word this is you
going on your social media platforms
whatever you're on and going hey I'm a
teacher and I'm now offering this course
or I'm offering this service and just
put out your information and you begin
to spread the word and so I think I
would look at both Pathways starting it
on your own and just putting the word
out on the old digital bulletin board if
you will and even listen even old school
bulletin board you know what I mean
you'd be surprised where you could get
some students
in your local church if they have a
community bulletin board that they
actually post or do they put a
newsletter out or if you're involved in
other Civic organizations and and
volunteering at your local Health Club
whatever whatever just get the word out
is the point don't overthink this after
you've decided what you're going to
offer and you got to be clear on how
much it costs and then get the word out
don't overthink it though but I would
look at that other pathway of are there
organizations that are just looking for
teachers to raise their hand and say yes
I can I can teach because that might be
the easiest pathway because now you're
not worried about the funnel you're just
okay I'm getting paid for my time and
I'm paying off debt that's exactly right
and there are a lot of uh websites too
that that get you can actually put your
name within it and you may have to pay a
small part of your fee to that point but
it might be worth it too on that end
because you're going to be able to have
yeah a huge funnel of clients that
you're not having to do the heavy
lifting yeah so Juan I love this I love
the intensity and I love that you want
to get out there and this is just an
encouragement to a lot of our audience
that may be new uh listening or or
viewing uh Rachel we are in this this
gig economy and this freelance economy
and it's booming yeah where
companies organizations are looking for
people who have an expertise and a skill
set
and they're okay paying you as a
contractor to deliver so those of you
that are trying to get out of debt I
would be looking at what can I do at
home at night and on the weekends based
on my current skill set you'd be
surprised what is available to you out
there because we've got this opportunity
in America now we have more jobs open
then we have people who are unemployed
so please know if you just go look you
might be surprised at what you can find
let's go to Aliana I hope I'm saying
that right in Anaheim California how can
we help
hi um yeah you said it just about right
it's Aliana Aliana all right I'll never
mess it up again what's going on
so I'm I'm pretty horrible with money
I've attempted to baby steps I think I'm
in like negative three baby steps
um but so basically what's going on
right now is I had a slip and fall
accident at Target about two years ago
oh no and
um my settlement's about to be coming
and I kind of got some news that when I
was doing my own research the lawyers
weren't giving me any like money like
demand information so I did my own
research and I estimated I'd get about
like 10 anywhere between ten thousand
and forty thousand and I talked to my
lawyer last week and they said that how
they do it is they asked for the full
demand like the full price that their
insurance Caps or something like that so
there's less wiggle room so they're
going to be demanding five million
dollars
not to say I have a five million dollar
case but it's definitely probably UPS
substantially what I thought I would be
getting
and I have no idea what I would do if I
even got a hundred thousand dollars okay
and I'll probably be getting that money
within about a month to two months from
now did you win the case
yeah it's they basically said like
they're just gonna send the demand and
then they negotiate and then I I get the
check so they're settling Target is
settling with you yes yeah Target is
settling okay uh do you what kind of
debt do you have
5000 dollars in debt okay
um how's that broken up 46 of that is in
school loans okay about broken up into
15 different ones okay and then about
like 9 000 and between loans and credit
cards okay all right so here's here's
the overarching red flag that I have for
you is that people think if I could just
get some money my life is gonna clear up
and everything's gonna be fine but the
problem is you take you with this big
pile of money so if you're not great
with money and you get a pile of money
you're going to be really not good with
money on a bigger scale so your money
habits are going to be really important
I would immediately pay off this debt
immediately put things in savings do not
go out and impulse buy so you hang on
the line because uh Emily's gonna pick
up and I want you to have a copy of my
book know yourself know your money and I
want you to start diving into
understanding how you are wired and
start having good money habits because
again bad money habits will be magnified
with a lot of money yeah thank you for
the call you're gonna get through this
hang on the line get the book read it
and do it you got this this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
all right America welcome back you've
joined the conversation here about your
life
your money your work your relationships
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
Rachel Cruz is my colleague and she
joins me this hour the phone number to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five Tyrell
is on the line in Philadelphia Tyrell
how can we help
hey guys I hope all is well it is
working out thank you I'm reaching out
because I work as a property manager and
I have a few uh side hustles that I do
as well I have a vehicle that I
purchased you know it's probably a
stupid purchase but basically I owe
thirty nine thousand dollars on this on
this street because it's a nice treat
and it's worth about 29 000 so I'm
upside down about ten thousand dollars
okay my uncle booties
sorry
no go ahead you're great I'm sorry go
ahead okay no worries my uncle believes
that I should uh I also have some money
coming in I'll work as a realtor to have
some bills that I'm closing and I have
about say about 15 000 coming in soon
and he believed that I should just pay
off my lower debts refinance the vehicle
to get a lower note
instead of
um paying the Delta and getting the jeep
completely off of my credit
okay so what other debt do you have
um so I'm in I'm in the hole about 79
000 total okay and that's uh I have I
have four cars total three of woods I
rent out on Toro so they actually make
some money I have about another
um everything else is pretty much credit
card and Home Improvement okay can we
walk through this really quick because I
think this this will help us of the
three of the three other cars that you
rent out on Touro I'm assuming you owe
money on all three is that right
yeah can you walk us through that uh
let's just say car number one you choose
what that is how much do you owe on that
and what is it worth
okay car number one on Toro there's I
have a Chevy Malibu right I owe 13 000
on that it's worth about eight thousand
and then I have two Nissan versas
they're both about 9 000 and they're
worth a little bit more than that
actually
and last but not least is my personal
vehicle my daily driver which is my Jeep
I owe 39 000 on that which is you know
only worth about 20. how much do you
make Tyrell a year
uh it it varies but last year I made a
hundred thousand a hundred thousand okay
does that include the turo side income
yes how much are you making a month on
all three of those cars together round
numbers on the turo cars
uh monthly on the Toro cars I'm making
roughly about 2500.
what are your car payments on the three
combined
about six hundred dollars combined
okay all right I wanted to gather that
information Rachel what are you thinking
okay so Tyrell here's the deal we we
said this in another segment and it's
just the truth what we have found over
three decades of doing this to create
wealth lasting wealth the right way from
point A to point B one of the biggest
things you can do is eliminate debt and
not have any payments and so when I'm
looking at the turo stuff and you're
like yeah I took out loans to get these
cars because it's kind of a business
thing it's a side hustle so like I know
you have the motivation and the
wherewithal to make money you're like I
wanna I wanna be doing some stuff but
with all of this debt flying around it
it is sucking not only your energy but
also your income and what you're doing
so if I were you if I woke up in your
shoes today
well well before I do the whole plan you
had a you said you had a home
improvement loan what was that for how
much it was done when we bought our
house a few years ago the HVAC blue and
they put it on what looked like a credit
card it was in Franklin Bank but uh all
about uh 4 000 on that right now 4 000
on that okay
so honestly Tyrell I would sell the two
nine thousand you said you can make some
money off that maybe you make you know I
don't know three four what do you think
what do you think those are worth the
two nine thousand dollar versus what are
they worth
they're worth right around uh ten
thousand maybe eleven right so you may
walk away two Grands but you just
knocked out eighteen thousand dollars in
debt yeah do you have any savings
uh I have about five grand savings five
Grand Savings okay so I would have a
401k okay so I would pause 401K
investing do not worry about investing
right now uh once you sell the two cars
you're gonna be able to knock out the
four thousand dollars with your four
thousand dollars in savings you're gonna
have two thousand dollars left from the
two cars that you sold and then I would
start working to pay off or to sell the
uh the first car that you're not your
primary car but the Terrell are yeah the
Malibu for thirteen thousand
um you're that's what you you owe
thirteen thousand you're only gonna get
you know eight thousand for it but yeah
are you saying we take the 4K out of
savings leaving him with a thousand
that's his emergency fund baby step one
yes and with the Thousand you're gonna
make on the two verses I wanna make sure
you heard what she said we're knocking
out the debt on all three of those turo
cars that and the HVAC the four thousand
dollars okay that's what I was wanting
to do the HVAC first I would do the HVAC
first because it's four thousand well
then you got that so then you got to
work on the the Malibu not that out yep
and then you're gonna work on that car
next and then honestly uh
you know we always say don't have 50 of
your income tied up in vehicles and if
you can't pay off your primary car in 18
months yeah you may look at selling it
and having to take out a hit of ten
thousand dollars of a small loan but if
you think you can pay it off in 18
months Tyrell you can keep your primary
car and that'll be the last thing that
you pay off yeah but I would get rid of
all this you just have stuff floating
around and honestly the the clarity that
comes when you don't have all of this
stuff that you're you're trying to
manage and all of it and you focus on
your real estate what you're doing and
then even get a side gig that you're not
having to go into debt for you can
always do that actually I would
encourage you to do that as you're
paying off this debt
um but I would I would realign your
energy and where you're looking to make
money off of debt and look to rewire
that to a place that actually is just
bringing you in income and not paying
payments does that make sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense I really
appreciate that yeah I know there was a
lot there sorry I hope I hope I
untangled that correctly for you if I
hope it was clear yeah but there the the
big thing here is I think you're a
really hard worker I think you're
motivated to make money and I think that
if you just Channel all of that the
right way versus using the bank's money
by taking out all these like small loans
and trying to do this churro thing and
you focus all of your energy on actually
a side hustle that you're killing it and
you take this 15 grand and you throw it
more at your debt that's coming in um
that 15 grand that you're gonna have for
your commission all of that all of this
is going to be bubbling up Tyrell and I
think this time next year you could be
completely debt free without question
and working your way towards an
emergency fund having some liquid cash
again and then yeah going back towards
retirement investing and all of it yeah
and Terrell our gift to you to get you
started we're going to get you NFP I
want you to take it on us because you
need to see that debt snowball working
for other people at the same time that
you're doing it and then my final
encouragement so hang on the line we're
gonna get you an FPU but I also want to
tell you this if I was in your shoes I
would absolutely get rid of the
distraction of turo and I would put my
efforts into real estate because the
upside there is so much greater and
you're entrepreneurial man I mean you
you've got the drive I think this is a
focus issue and I think it's a
discipline issue and I think you've
learned the hard lesson it's not worth
buying a brand new car I don't care how
cool the Jeep commercial is during the
Super Bowl and believe me it made me
think about it it got me all patriotic
and I want a Jeep you know but here's
the deal like it doesn't pay off because
now you're looking at getting out of
that deal so you know I think you've
learned the lessons young man I think
your future is really bright let's get
you an FPU let's give you the clear path
and some accountability and some
community that you'll get and I think
Rachel's right we're gonna look back my
friend and you're going to be a baby
steps millionaire because you got the
hustle that's right that's a great point
about the side hustle yes if you're
already in something like a real acryl
estate that you just make some Great
Commission and you put more time into
that you could kill it yeah man I love
we've got we had some calls uh when was
it the last like I guess Wednesday when
I was on with Dave two different times
we were doing the millionaire theme our
real estate agents no college degree
yeah everyday Millionaires and they're
making 300 a year selling real estate
I'm like man what a what a what a world
we live in those are my people I know no
degree required baby I don't need a
degree to be successful I don't need a
degree to make six figures I live in
America
you know so there you go hey great hour
Rachel Cruz always fun to be with you my
friend I want to thank James and the
entire crew behind the glass to keep us
on the air but mostly want to thank you
America this is your show this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money and
when we talk about your money that means
we're talking about your relationships
and your work because they're all
connected so we're here to give you
practical Solutions that'll give you a
hope so that you can step out and live
the life that you're supposed to live
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number if you want to
jump in with your question triple eight
eight two five five two two five Rachel
Cruz joins me this hour and we are here
for you and let's talk about
probably the biggest money issue
in the nation it's the number one
headline it is inflation as a result of
that big bumper sticker issue Rachel
which is inflation we're looking at
interest rates it has been the ongoing
narrative for some time as the Federal
Reserve you may hear it referred to as
the fed and Jerome Powell I call him our
feckless Fed chair more on that in a
moment but the FED during the pandemic
they flooded a lot of liquid cash into
the market because of what happened in
2020 with the uncertainty of the
pandemic people being laid off in Mass
companies worried are we going to be
able to stay open and you heard of the
PPP loans the federal government the FED
putting money out into the marketplace
and we saw on the back side of that in
2021 Rachel an unbelievable boom in the
job market four million jobs were
created coming out of the pandemic it
was almost a surreal reaction to are
businesses failing well the government
came in gave them cash forgave the loans
and so companies that were worried about
dying were flush with cash Rachel based
on your money expertise
what do people do when they come into a
lot of money what's the number one
Temptation reaction to do with the money
is it to save it I'm gonna say to spend
it oh Kenneth thank you thank you very
much for the Kenneth reference well
companies did that and they did it in
the form of hiring and so we are in an
unprecedented job market with a 3.4
percent unemployment rate we have more
jobs available
then there are people who are unemployed
almost two to one now I'm just setting
the context for why are we still in an
inflationary period the number one
reason that we're still in inflation is
because over the last two and a half
three years the great resignation where
people were leaving companies and
getting paid a whole lot more it took
the cost of hiring Talent up that
includes hourly
and salary and as a result your
groceries your combo meals pretty much
every area of Life the clothing you
bought for twenty dollars is now 25 we
understand that so I'm setting the
context for this Rachel because I I'm
about to reveal something that I can't
believe I'm about to say I can't even
believe I'm saying it publicly I didn't
think I'd say it privately but Senator
Elizabeth Warren I don't agree with her
on just about anything
but she recently had
Jerome Powell in first of March
at a congressional hearing and she put
him to the test now Jerome Pals the Fed
chair he's the guy that kind of is the
front man for the Federal Reserve and
they're deciding are we going to
continue to raise interest rates
now before I let you see this clip and
they're raising interest rates oh
they're trying to stop to stop inflation
to stop inflation to stop having people
in the market buying stuff right you're
trying to counter it but you got it and
so their weapon is I'm gonna raise rates
well that has caused a lot of pain we
all know that but inflation hasn't gone
down now I want to show you a clip and
then I'm going to walk you through and
some of you are going why are you going
through this because at the end of this
I'm going to reveal what this monetary
policy actually means for you in your
day-to-day life and what you can do
about it okay but we got to see this
this is unbelievable so she's
questioning him and she's going you are
openly saying that raising the interest
rates
is going to drive the unemployment
number up she puts him to the test watch
this one minute confrontation
if you'll continue raising interest
rates as you plan unemployment will be
4.6 percent by the end of the year and
that would be about 2 million people if
you could speak directly to the 2
million who you're planning to get fired
over the next year what would you say to
them inflation is extremely high and
it's hurting the working people of this
country badly all of them not just 2
million of them and we are taking the
the only measures we have to bring
inflation down and putting too many
too many part of the cost
well they will will working people be
better off if if we just walk away from
our jobs and and inflation remains five
six percent there have been 12 times
that we've seen a one point increase in
in the unemployment rate in a year how
many times did the economy fail to fall
into a recession after doing that out of
12 times I think the number is zero I
think the number is zero that's exactly
right
ouch Elizabeth Warren bring in the Heat
and this is where I'm shocked but I
actually agree with her uh this is a
situation where Jerome Pyle folks has
gone on record many times you can get on
the Google if you think I'm making this
up and he has said it is an unfortunate
pain point that we're going to have to
get to to see unemployment go up and his
idea is if unemployment goes up because
we are raising the cost of borrowing
raising the cost of doing business that
companies will lay people off now we've
seen big Tech do that and he's flirting
with a recession because he's hoping
that people will companies will lay
people off what happens then is is the
job demand goes down in his mind
and so now people aren't having to pay
as much because he knows that wage
pressures Rachel are causing right
inflation to be stubborn here's the
challenge with what he said
it's not the only tool he has
the FED screwed this up the FED flushed
too much money into the economy and got
us to this point because they were
worried about the pandemic this is what
happens when the federal government and
the Federal Bank gets involved in the
economy he then says ironically what you
would you have us do Senator Warren walk
away from our jobs Yes actually I would
like you feckless fed share pal to walk
away and just let the economy figure out
do its thing here's why
yes inflation has made a household
budget much higher however
to force two million people or maybe
more because here's the deal these are
projections we're at three point four
percent unemployment right now historic
lows if it gets pushed and there are
quotes where he said Rachel it may get
to six percent unemployment and that may
be what it takes so you're gonna drive
millions of people
to unemployment
and you think that's going to fix it but
here's the issue we've got five to six
million jobs available
I know I'm paying it off we've got five
to six million jobs available right now
in this economy so if you drive an
unemployment they're gonna go get
another job and we're not going to fix
it and oh by the way let's step back
Rachel has the interest rate increase
done anything to unemployment so far no
it has not he's been steadily raising
the rates and unemployment is still
still low because there's so many jobs
so why does this matter to you folks who
come to a money show because we have
debt free screamers every day on this
show every week every month and
inflation isn't affecting them because
they're not looking to DC in the fed and
interest rates they're taking control of
their money so these headlines and while
it is painful you can control your money
no matter how expensive groceries are
you can actually control your future
through your spending and your saving
and Ramsay Solutions and the Ramsey show
is here to help you do it we don't care
what Jerome Powell does at the end of
the day because he doesn't have a
freaking clue and we are in control of
our money we got you don't worry about
the headlines this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz so excited to have you with
us triple eight eight two five five two
two five is the number if you got a
money question a work create a work
question related to to uh getting more
money or yeah just getting out of a
nasty situation happy to take those
calls as well uh if you're enjoying the
show we'd love for you to consider
subscribing following us leaving a
review and sharing with a friend if this
information is helping you we'd love to
help as many people as possible get some
hope filled practical advice so they can
move forward in their life so thank you
so very much for that let's go to
Ashland Wisconsin Julie's there Julie
how can we help
hi
um thanks for taking my call I really
enjoy your show
um I do I have a housing question uh
well and I think it's probably a
national thing and and pretty much
everywhere in northern Wisconsin There's
a very low inventory of any homes
um anyway I did have a house at one
point that I had sold about two and a
half years ago and had moved in with my
boyfriend at the time who's now my ex so
that's that story
um now I'm renting a very small
apartment
um it was all I could find and I don't
know what makes sense at my age because
I'll probably work until Social Security
or excuse me until Medicare age so
that's four years off for me
and uh I just don't know what makes the
most sense if I should just keep on
trying to rent and
um go that route instead of purchasing a
home in this climate or in this market
sure
um okay Julie when or how much debt do
you have any Consumer Debt
um no what I accumulate on credit cards
is pretty much paid off every month so
okay but no personal loans no car loans
nope okay and how much paid off and how
much do you have in retirement
um I have about 400 000 in a 401k and
344 of that is pre-tax and 56 000 is
Roth right now okay and I also have
pension that's about valued at about 400
at about 400 okay
do you have any liquid cash right now
yes I have the the proceeds from a house
and a little bit of combined savings
which is around 70. around 70 000. okay
and just how much is how much is a house
uh in your area going for even a small
one or even a condo a town home
yeah the problem there really isn't a
condo or town home
um
Market uh it's just there's a shortage
in general but you know probably a
mediocre house maybe 150 at the bottom
which is you're not going to get much
um you got to get closer to like 180 or
maybe higher to get something that's
halfway's decent that's there yeah so
okay
well here's my thing is owning a home is
a great
part of your financial overall plan
because when it's paid off it's going to
have all that equity and it's going to
be part of your net worth and so you
kind of can just start to build on that
and so I think there would be
um I would I would encourage you to look
towards that soon but like you said with
your age and where you're at I don't
want you having a massive mortgage
payment going into retirement either and
so exactly and how much do you make a
year
82 82 okay
so
yeah with this I mean if you want to
slowly start saving and then maybe pull
the trigger in five six years
um if you have the cash saved up and
looking to see okay yeah I can put a big
down payment or half of this home
um again I just don't want you getting
to the point where you want to stop
working but you have to keep working
just to fund a mortgage payment but
you're going to have to be funding rent
anyway so like you're gonna have to live
somewhere and exactly yep so it would be
you know to your benefits to own a home
uh to for it to be working towards
equity and all that towards your
financial picture but again I don't want
you to do something that's going to end
up harming you so there is that balance
there so you do have a great savings and
again some of that is going to be for
your emergency funds and what you live
off of so I would be working and putting
as much money away as possible to save
up for again I mean I would try to put
down 50 60 down on a home I mean that
would be yeah that would be incredible
and on a home that really is uh the
right home for you you know let's not go
overboard here let's take care of you it
needs to be comfortable for you
um you know you don't know what's going
to happen relationally you know are you
single Julie still yeah
um the other question I had is as far as
what I'm putting into my um 401k if I
should be putting more in savings
instead of I I actually reduced it I was
putting 16 in part of that was Roth of
course and now I've lowered that down to
um
seven percent no eight percent
um Roth and three percent pre-tax and so
I don't know if I should increase that
you know in conjunction with just yeah
do you have do you have a Roth IRA
yes like I said yes like about
um of my portfolio of the 400 000 in
their um 56 000 now that is Ross the 56.
okay okay I apologize yeah so I would go
up to the match to the 401K I would
flood the rest into the Roth and then
you're only at eight percent right now
so I would I would be funding 15 uh
especially at your age right now and so
whatever the remainder of that is income
wise I would go back to the 401K and do
that until your income is at that 15
Mark yep Julie are you single okay
yes okay
any plans
any plans yeah are we hoping that man
comes along or are we talking about here
I'm not holding my breath
yeah but the reason I ask that is I want
you to have the mindset I want you to be
hopeful for a relationship of course but
I want you to have the mindset what was
life looking like and what do I really
need given the fact that I'm single
that's that's what I'm getting at I want
to make sure that you're because because
you could always if you get that kind of
house or a town home or whatever like
Rachel said you got that Hefty down
payment it's really setting yourself up
you still have options if the
relationship Factor changes
right right so oh yeah yeah so but I
would be I would be funding usually we
would say hey to save up for a home
pause everything and save up baby step
3B but with your age Julie I would I
would do the 15 and then anything on the
side and if you can live on half your
income I mean within three years you're
gonna have some serious money to go and
buy something so that would be my
encouragement is that I want a house in
your future
um but take your time let it be slow and
again do not do not do something
financially that that's going to force
you into delaying retirement or anything
you know if you want to be working I
want it for you to be working because
you want to and maybe because you have a
realistic hey in three years my house is
going to be paid off type mentality uh
them getting into something for on a
30-year mortgage or whatever that you're
it's going to be forever and ever amen
so
um being really aggressive with it but I
think I think owning something going
into retirement is going to be is going
to be a great goal for you I do too do
you want to travel do you see yourself
what is what does retirement look like
to you
well definitely I would like to do some
traveling and then my other love is
music I had originally gone to school
for music so I'm actively working on
that and and looking at that as somewhat
of a side sole proprietor to ship type
thing
um good and so that what I'm looking at
with that and I've talked to tax
advisors on that is you know to help
offset the cost with driving gigs with
um you know try to get that to balance
out to zero so to speak and it might
help my taxable consequence with my day
job okay good all right well you've
gotta you've gotta you got a great
vision and you I think you have the
ability to do it and I think it's so
important for folks to to in every
season of life let's what really matters
most and let's make those big financial
decisions on that yeah not the ideal yep
what matters most so I I think he gave
her great advice and and uh you know
it's
it's amazing to me what happens when
people kind of get super clear on
something they go okay this is what
really really matters here this is what
I need and now I'm going to work towards
that as opposed to having all these
different ideas and not locking in yeah
on a very clear goal it's really
important because the discipline and all
the things we teach will work the focus
if you know what you're going towards I
think that's important right so that's
really fun well thank you so much for
the call Julie we're excited for you the
best is yet to be speaking of the best
is yet to be there's a couple more
segments in the shower don't go anywhere
she's Rachel Cruz I'm Ken Coleman this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz
this hour we're here for you taking your
calls Triple eight eight two five five
two two five now Rachel uh you're you're
way more advanced than me uh on social
media a lot
that look at you taking a shot of me but
it's fair you really are life in life
yeah just I'm just a loser compared to
you but one of the things you're really
good at and you're you're just you're
just Adept you're on the talk you're on
the gram you're really good at all the
social stuff and I'm just a middle-aged
guy trying to figure out what to figure
this out yeah what's going on but the
reason I'm bringing this up is I'm
assuming you've heard these terms quiet
quitting and bare minimum Monday have
you heard these terms they're huge on
Tick Tock bear minimum Monday yeah so
bare minimum Monday is a very famous
tick tocker has come up with a way to
like I gotta ease into Monday I I need a
little bit more time than Saturday and
Sunday just so much these things are
huge Trends and and and and so here's
the point
this is an excuse for complacency for
living an average life like like you
just can't win you can't find a job that
you're really good at that you enjoy
that gives you a ladder to grow
financially and live a life you want
this is the mentality and I fight this
stuff every day and one of the tools
we've developed here at Ramsey Solutions
is the get clear assessment now what is
this it's about a 15 to 18 minute uh
assessment and it measures three things
I developed this the team helped me turn
it into something and it measures three
things Rachel what I'm good at what I
actually enjoy doing and what motivates
me now this is an important tool because
it leads to one clear thing awareness
awareness of self is how I'm wired is
how I'm unique and then it makes me
aware of Pathways to a profession where
I actually really enjoy showing up and
by the way the financial payoff is is
exciting as well so that's the tool
that's what it does it's on a special
deal right now uh it's a 30. investment
is ten dollars off right now until
midnight and it's going nuts on the
Ramsey store this month because of this
special deal go check it out
ramseysolutions.com get clear
ramseysolutions.com get clear you get a
detailed report in those three areas
what I'm good at what I love to do what
motivates me and then we put it together
in a purpose statement so you have your
own purpose of it this is who I am and
who I want to be and what I want to do
so go check it out
I'm very proud it's a great oh it's like
it's so good and actually my
um family member brother-in-law took it
absolutely and raved about it we did a
deep dive I know it's so good so I mean
like honestly it's really it yeah but
it's such a helpful tool thank you and
the fact we live in a world today where
stuff can like that can be out and you
can use it to your advantage I mean do
it this allows you to be uniquely you so
go check it out all right let's go to D
oh this is great I if I if I wasn't
named Ken I think this is the name that
I would like you would take this next I
think I'd take this name let's go to
dino in Tampa Florida Dino how can we
help
well first of all it's an honor to talk
to both of you I'm a big time regular
fan and listener and I really appreciate
the advice you give me whatever it be um
just asking me to differentiate between
my position and uh my wife's okay oh boy
this is great I'm gonna I'm gonna come
at it from Dino's perspective and Rachel
will come at it from your wife's we'll
see what happens it is all right I'll
try to give you a synopsis now we we are
well as of 30 days ago we were
completely debt free we own our homes
congratulations well thank you you thank
you I even have a rental house that it's
100 paid for so amazing Tino right yeah
we think we're finally do we really
suffered to get to where we're at and if
all the beans and rice is they say it's
true I'm not at the seven figure number
but I'm I'm tracking it down you're
getting there what well what I wanted to
do is right so my business is heavy into
um real estate and I have a fantastic
they call them a whale client he's like
you know he's a great great client and
he's responsible for a huge huge portion
of our business and long story short
he's invited us to attend um his party
the birthday party up in New York City
which is going to cost us a couple of
bucks now hold on hold on to give us the
full detail I gotta know how much is it
gonna cost you because I know this is
where this is headed
well the thing is I kind of left
something out there we just bought this
we just bought it my wife a car brand
new
um and I anticipate on paying that thing
off you know in less than six months for
sure
um
you told us you were debt free well I
know as of 30 days ago
yeah I have to retract the screen for
about six months but uh but you don't
get to do that so now
go to New York no you can't I do I
didn't do the screen for for what it's
worth yeah it's okay but you can't go to
New York you can't go it's gonna cost
you a lot you didn't answer my question
how much it was even gonna cost but you
can't do it do you not have cash to the
bank do you know to pay off this car
yeah yeah I've got I've got about 25
Grand in the bank 15 in my savings and
12 or so in my working account
um I I paid for the tickets already
um the you know it's gonna cost me about
3 000 more but we're not going on a
summer vacation because Fort Myers got
destroyed so I'm kind of you know also
subtracting in by addition they're kind
of okay Dino we know what's happening
who what's the wife's position and
what's yours let's get to the drama
that's right Dina wants to go you want
to go to New York
not only is it going to be awesome yeah
of course of course it is do you know
fomo what's that Start Spreading the
News Dino's leaving today
and she thinks we should hunker down
now she's already dridled with guilt
over the car why didn't you go buy a 25
000 car
I I bought a forty eight thousand
dollars why
because that was she's been doing
without for so long
such a great guy Dino he got the truck
she got the the big one the nice truck
and so one and done though I've checked
that off the bucket list I won't ever be
asked from her to buy a car again
um but that's the deal you know well you
could go to New York if she sells the
car back to the dealer we make up the
difference
hey just throw a high fastball right
under Dino's chin and he's thinking
about it
for real in six months six months you
know um what do you want us to say you
you started the call saying I really
love the show you give me good advice
and you thought we were going to give
you a pass I thought you were
you know you're you're you know you can
handle three G's you know
what I mean okay and here's the deal
could you sure but also there's a
discipline factor of like new you guys
put yourselves back in a financial hole
yeah yeah
and it's like all right now everything's
focused on getting this car paid off
you know on the negative side will it
hurt my career because this guy is in
charge of no more than she says it won't
matter he doesn't care but Idina I don't
want this to hurt your feelings he
doesn't care if you don't show up he's
gonna be pretty happy with or without
you he's gonna be in New York
you should go watch the movie in the car
because I'm sure that's a DVD player
good cold
I'm not going to New York is what I'm
saying what you're saying I think we
made it abundantly clear Dino oh Kenny I
thought you were gonna be a little bit
nicer to me hey Dino are you called the
Ramsay show yeah all all of our cars we
say beans and rice rice and beans you do
nothing until your debt gets paid off we
got really quick though I do have to go
back or have so much fun with you Dino
did you say you already had paid some of
the money towards the the New York whale
trip
yes sir I um you know I uh can you get
it back
well I can probably get a credit from
the airline I I had to come my company
paid for it and um you know it's already
booked how much left would be on the
trip uh if you if you what's the rest of
it
you figure it was like 500 bucks for the
tickets it wasn't all that much if they
give me a credit they might charge me a
hundred bucks a ticket so I'll have a
little bit of credit if you want to yeah
but I'm saying how much more money would
you have to put towards the trip
probably 2500 you gotta do two hotels
yeah yeah 900 bucks a night for the
hotel and then no you know we're getting
up we're getting a private Gap tour of
New York and we're taking us up oh man
Dino Dino I I gotta tell you I I really
want you to go see the whale client I
really want you to take a yacht trip
around New York City I mean it sounds
amazing but it feels like you got to
have some pain in order to do this you
got to sell something maybe sell the car
hey I really would just sell that car
though y'all it's that's not worth it go
ahead get rid of it it's depreciating
right now it's not worth it then go walk
she's gonna be okay in two years she'll
sell the car and go to New York then go
to New York tell them to buy that get
that whale Harpoon him get him to buy
something else and enjoy the ice for the
new car watch the DVD
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show thrilled
to have you I'm Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
joins me this hour
the phone number to jump into triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our scripture of the day comes from
Ecclesiastes one verse 8 everything is
weary some Beyond description well can
we just pause right there that's what
I'm feeling sometimes he had three
teenagers I'm exhausted
back to the Bible no matter how much we
see We are Never Satisfied no matter how
much we hear we are not content our
quote comes from Bob Lazar or laser I
don't know is it Lazar thank you very
much I'm Hooked on Phonics there is much
that appears initially to be black and
white and absolute but later is revealed
to be more gray than white or black and
I'm getting cheer hands over here from
you you got a little something to add to
that no you like that that is the that's
what I've learned the older I get the
Greater Life is yeah that was curated
for you Rachel is that for me do you
know who that is no he's like an aliens
conspiracy theory guy oh is he
see which explains why I didn't know his
name I stay away from the conspiracies
anything I know about that friends from
you and I Dive Right In wow talk about
it I should have known that I don't know
why that didn't that didn't ring about
guys you don't know why he's talking
about the gray the gray in life and why
you did praise hands there's a lot I
know
it's not being revealed folks in my soul
so a million dollars seems to be the end
goal for a lot of people uh but in
today's economy the question is is it
really enough to retire on so listen no
one likes surprises especially when
you're ready to retire and go on the
beach and enjoy your life you don't want
to realize that you don't have enough to
cover your day-to-day expenses so in
this week's edition of the Ramsey
newsletter we answer the question on
whether you can still retire on a
million dollars so to get the question
answered simply sign up at
ramsesolutions.com newsletter to
subscribe to our Sunday newsletter and
learn more on how much you need to have
for retirement and this is perfect
timing because Kelly happens to be on
hold in Rochester New York and I think
may you have a retiring question Kelly
how can we help
yeah so thanks for taking my call
um so I hope to retire in about four
years I'll be 59 soon I um will have a
New York state pension
um and that should equal about 47 000 um
you know gross then plus Social Security
I have really no Investments at this
point I'll be probably finished with
that baby step three
um mid-november good
um it depends on you know what I think I
really need to have you know is my
safety net so my question is should I
really I really want to get my mortgage
paid off before I retire I mean I know
it's gonna be hard work but um if I do
that then I really I would if I took the
15 and invested that you know
um after step three I would not be able
to
pay my mortgage off because that's going
to be you know that would be probably be
half of what I would be putting towards
extra towards my mortgage
um you know I have the possibility being
able to work part-time after I retire
but you know for what I'm doing right
now I can go
that's my plan has to stop in four years
okay so how much do you make a year
um let's see so I'm at 86
000 and then that'll go up every three
percent for 3.5 for the next four years
three point seven five percent okay so
86 and how much is left on the house
107. 107. okay
yeah so it's always that that balance of
wanting to retire because if you pour
everything into the house but you don't
have any cash cheap money to eat off of
then that puts you in a predicament uh
but then also you don't want to be left
with a massive mortgage payment that
you're having to pay uh out of your
retirement so it really is kind of
walking that that fine line Kelly
um right so if you can be doing I mean
honestly to where it is at both and and
if I were you I know you what do you do
for a job because I know you're saying
you're wanting to retire in four years
uh yes I'm an occupational therapist
okay okay so what if you did work an
extra two years beyond what you wanted
um and you ran the math out would that
be able to help with the mortgage
significantly
like I'm just thinking another eighty
six thousand dollars I mean a hundred
and you know eighty thousand by that
point two years of working are you still
going to be able to push through to the
mortgage
Kelly I mean I guess I'd have to really
sit down and figure it out do you do
occupational therapy for the state
uh it's for in the school district yeah
okay that's what I was wondering because
you mentioned the pension and to back to
Rachel's question the reason I asked the
question back to Rachel's question I
mean you're you're looking at four more
years to be able to collect the state
retirement pension right but to her
point an occupational therapist in the
private sector is going to make a good
bit more than you would for the state
and so even if you worked Less hours and
I think that's where Rachel's going okay
we retire from the state we get the
pension that's nice you put your time in
but I only can pay the house off if I
work three or four more years so that I
get the investment going now and I could
pay the house off even when I walk away
from the state job I'm just wondering
because you're still going to be
relatively young I mean 59 and four I
mean you're 63 that's pretty young are
you planning just to stop working all
together
no good no my plan was I I was thinking
about doing some travel therapy and go
across country and you know Charlie I
love that because of the travel pays
better
yeah oh it definitely does you know but
again you know I don't know what you
know in four years like what's that
gonna look like plus you know if if and
either one of my children have a baby I
want to be able to be around to help and
things like that sure Kelly have you
looked into the private sector at all I
just wonder even for the remaining four
to five years of you working
here's the trade-off
you you may yeah you know what I mean
you may be paying less into your pension
but the point is is that you're making
money
yes but it's it's definitely a lot more
hours and
um you know just not at that stage in my
life I've been that therapist for over
you know almost 35 years yeah that's
just the whole home care so here's my
point
um I think that would be something I
could definitely fall back on so what I
would what you're saying though I could
kind of split it yeah and then good good
but I would be I would be funding still
15 of your income into retirement
you would okay yes absolutely and then
and then anything else I'm sorry
he'd like to a Roth maybe yeah yep
exactly I'd be opening a Roth IRA and I
would sit down with a smart Vester Pro
Kelly in your area there in Rochester uh
because they're going to be able to run
again because they may put you in more
aggressive funds you know because of
your age they're going to help really
guide you when it comes to get the most
for your retirement and then when that
pension comes out you're going to be
wanting to invest that uh and and and
use that money as well on living
obviously so any money that you can
still put away at retirement 15 and I
mean man I just always know those so
close to retirement age you know even I
mean a teeter's at 15. I mean even a
little bit more if you want to throw
extra it's just you I want you to have a
be able to eat and travel and do the
things that you want to do at retirement
as well as starting to see that mortgage
chip away so I would be doing both Kelly
but I would sit down if yeah if you
don't have you know a vehicle like a
Roth IRA or other things besides the
pension I would be looking into that
because I want to pull out as much money
as possible again into that retirement
but also at the same time looking at the
goal of the house and you just make
great money and so looking ahead to say
okay what if I do work another year or
two past retirement age even at less
hours even at less hours Kelly you are
in great shape walk the baby steps out
you're almost done with three let's go
to four get fully engaged in four and
then you skip right to paying the house
off at six and I I just you won't regret
this get with a smart Master Pro as
Rachel says and they'll help you see the
specifics of what we're talking about
real numbers and then how long will take
you to pay off that house even after 64.
I love it and I mean she's 107 left on
the home so I'm like she can do this
yeah and still enjoy the grandbabies and
still travel yep and I I just love this
so walk it out and I want to see
something really quickly I this is this
is not a hot take it may be
controversial but I I want to share this
with people we were talking about
retirement right now
you can go do your own research on this
I don't have data to hit you with
specifically but the data is very clear
that Rachel when we retire people that
when they go from working to no working
at all I mean just like we're done the
physical and the mental decline the
emotional decline is substantive and so
wow slow down yes but I'm not retiring I
will work until I hit the desk and
that's it for me and I think that's how
we're wired to do it hopefully not here
on the show it'd be terrible that would
be just but I will tell you it's sad
it'd be pretty memorable though hey
Rachel Cruz great hour I'll always enjoy
being with you James Childs our fearless
leader and the crew thank you guys and
to you America thank you this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Rams and
baby steps go to ramsesolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramseysolutions.com and
click get started
[Music]